23 вересня в інтерв'ю "ТСН.Тиждень"
на телеканалі 1+1 генеральний прокурор Юрій Луценко,
коментуючи протистояння між Національним Антикорупційним Бюро України
і Спеціалізованою Антикорупціїною прокуратурою,
заявив про відсутність результатів в роботі НАБУ:
Хто б і як до кого не відносився  з керівників силових структур,
вони мають у співпраці добиватися суспільного результату.
Да, я розумію, що після цього інтерв'ю маса борців з корупцією,
які живуть за рахунок іноземних грантів,
скажуть, що я знову дискредитую НАБУ.
Я просто цитую, що у них немає результатів. Їх не існує.
Як уточнила DW прес-секретарка генпрокурора України Лариса Сарган,
у відсутності результатів роботи НАБУ
Юрій Луценко мав на увазі відсутність вироків ТОП-корупціонерам.
У цій ситуації слід нагадати, що НАБУ
здійснює досудове розслідування.
САП дає дозволи на слідчі дії детективам НАБУ,
зокрема прослуховування або стеження.
Коли доказів достатньо, прокурори підписують справу і передають її до суду.
Коли справа в суді, НАБУ вже не впливає на її хід.
Далі триває робота антикорупційної прокуратури і суду.
Станом на березень 2018 року за результатом розслідування НАБУ
винесено дійсно небагато вироків - загалом 22.
них три справи завершились засудженням підзрюваних,
а 19 - повним визнанням провини, досудовою угодою зі слідством
або компенсацією збитків в бюджет.
Згідно з даними незалежного аналізу діяльності НАБУ,
оприлюдненого у березні 2018 року,
міжнародні експерти дійшли висновку, що з моменту свого створення
у 2015 році Національне бюро діяло результативно
та досягло необхідного рівня ефективності.
Серед авторів експертної доповіді,
зокрема, керівник слідчого управління Генеральної інспекції Міністерства юстції США
та екс-заступник державного прокурора Данії з питань економічних злочинів.
В експертному звіті йдеться, що НАБУ розпочало
543 кримінальні провадження,
вручило 181 повідомлення про підозру
та арештувало понад 654 мільйони гривень
і 160 мільйонів доларів.
Крім того, 120 кримінальних проваджень НАБУ - в судах на розгляді.
Також експерти зауважили, що повною мірою
оцінити результативність НАБУ буде можливо лише після того,
як суди завершать розгляд тих справ,
в яких обвинувачені не визнають свою провину.
У незалежному звіті діяльності НАБУ експерти рекомендують
чимшвидше створити новий Вищий антикорупційний суд
та на відкритому конкурсі відібрати до нього професійних суддів
з високим рівнем доброчесності.
У такому випадку Антикорупційне Бюро
може досягти максимальних результатів.
За даними березневого моніторингу Ради громадського контролю НАБУ,
суди не в змозі оперативно розглянути справи,
скеровані НАБУ та САП. Багато антикорупційних проваджень «провисає»,
тому що такі справи може розглядати лише колегія з трьох суддів.
68% від призначених судових засідань не відбулося.
Основна причина -  відсутність повного складу суду.
Один із факторів результативності НАБУ - ефективне використання коштів.
Експерти не знайшли жодних фактів нецільового використання наданих НАБУ грошей.
Водночас Бюро має брак кадрів через обмеження чисельності його штату,
визначене в законі.
Однак попри це,  НАБУ успішно започаткувало
та довело до завершення низку антикорупційних розслідувань
проти посадових осіб вищого рівня державної влади,
суддів, прокурорів,  а також інших впливових суб’єктів,
які раніше були недоторканними.
"Без співпраці з САП ефективна робота НАБУ неможлива" -
у цій  частині своєї заяви Юрій Луценко має рацію.
Однак твердження генпрокурора про те,
що "не існує" результатів роботи НАБУ,
ігнорує відомі факти. НАБУ ефективно виконуює
свою роботу у здійсненні досудового розслідування.
Це підтвердженно міжнародною експертною перевіркою.
А відсутність вироків у резонансних справах свідчить про те,
що проблема не в "результативності" НАБУ, а в судах,
які не працюють належним чином - через відсутність судової реформи,
яку українська влада не проводить належним чином.